en naviguant dans l'univers internet les
enfants canadiens sont bombardés de
publicités alimentaires
on a regardé les dix sites préférés des
enfants puis on a trouvé plus de 50
millions pub alimentaire sur ces sites
là alors c'est un très grand nombre
puis quand on fait l'analyse
nutritionnelle de ces de ces produits là
c'est 90 % et + et des produits qu'on
catégorise comme malsain c'étaient les
gâteaux les biscuits le fast food et
breuvages sucrés
le red bull c'était le produit numéro
trois sur ces sites là alors c'est quand
même assez surprenant
la chercheuse money pots-de-vin kent
développe un protocole de surveillance
pour restreindre le marketing
alimentaire
elle a répertorié ce que peuvent voir
les enfants dans une m
c'est un jeu sur à cet enfant sur ce
site de jeux de mathématiques très
populaire par exemple se glisse
facilement différentes marques
parce que tracas ne sais quoi non c'est
à pour la pleine force pour la malbouffe
pour un enfant c'est juste le fun c'est
différent c'est un enfant c'est même de
10 11 ans comprend que ça c'est des
publicités pas nécessairement la ccc
beaucoup plus difficile même les
adolescents ont beaucoup plus de
difficultés à reconnaître les publicités
en ligne
à cause qui est un croisement entre
divertissement et publicité
[Musique]
il y a les sites mais il ya aussi tout
le web à l'école sophie-barat dans cette
classe de 1er secondaire et avec des
étudiants de 3e secondaire
nous faisons une expérience on a demandé
aux enfants de naviguer sur leurs
réseaux sociaux préférés afin de savoir
ce qu'ils allaient voir comme publicité
tout le monde est prêt ok vous allez sur
le réseau le 7 ou le jeu bublé dans
trois de hop c'est parti
durée du test cinq minutes
qu'est ce que tu as trouvé tweaks ckoi
tweet si un chocolat bas il y avait
beaucoup de réaux de 2,4 est ce que tu
es sur le site de cadbury ou non non je
suis je suis sur instagram de vue w ce
bruit l'homme jusqu'en qu'est ce que ça
vous donne envie de manger ce midi une
publicité de starbucks de boisson
énergisante comme dans tout jeu mais
aujourd'hui j'ai des gens n'est pas venu
c'est une liste et les ténors sont
légion à une saisie et les poires un job
ainsi en quelques secondes les premières
publicités et les influenceurs défilent
au total c'est près d'une quarantaine
chez les plus jeunes
alors que c'est plus d'une cinquantaine
de publicité qui sont apparus sur les
cellulaires des adolescents
nostalgique ça bastonne les stocks des
résultats comparables à ceux de madame
pots-de-vin kent qui avait aussi
analyser les médias sociaux des jeunes
les enfants un pelage de 7 ans et 12 ans
leur exposition au marketing alimentaire
sûre comme en ligne sur les médias
sociaux c'est à peu près 1500 publicité
par année tandis que les adolescents
leur exposition c'est une plus de 9000
publicité par année alors c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus pour les adolescents cause
et passe beaucoup plus de temps sur les
médias sociaux les jours d'école je peux
penser du genre sinclair à 6 heures et
la fin de semaine s'appelle jusqu'à 10
aces qui venus déguster d'alcool
beaucoup parce que ça vous influence
mais pas pour de la vodka mais ce serait
pour d'autres choses oui c'est quelqu'un
qu'on aime donc c'est sûr qu'on a envie
de faire comme une 2% des publicités
c'était pour des produits alcooliques il
ya de la réglementation qui dit qu'on
peut pas cibler les enfants avec ses
produits l'obsession des sept enfants il
y a plus de 30 ans le québec s'est doté
d'une loi qui interdit toute forme de
publicité auprès des enfants de moins de
13 ans et sites web eux font partie de
la législation québécoise un site web
québécois ne pourrait pas intéressé s
adresse directement des enfants ce
serait illégal
le mécanisme d'application de la loi
repose beaucoup sur les épaules du
consommateur parce que c'est un
mécanisme de plainte à l'office de
protection du consommateur a encore
faut-il que les gens connaissent la loi
soient sensibilisés à la loi décide de
porter plainte
voilà la somme non voilées la coalition
poids s'est donné comme mandat de
surveiller les compagnies fautives
on est capable de porter plainte on l'a
déjà fait pour lockheed charme qui
invitait son à boîte de serial les
enfants les visiteurs allaient s'amuser
avec le personnage de l'eau qui dort
on a porté plainte à l'office de la
protection du consommateur et il ya eu
condamnation mais ce qu'on sait si le
marketing ont un impact important sur
les habitudes de consommation et sur la
santé de nos enfants
alors c'est le monde cela n'est pas sûr
qu est ce qu ils mangent qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent manger qu'est ce que
préfère manger et leur leur taux
d'obésité oreo ça ça vous influence ou
sport oui en ce moment j'ai envie de
manger des oeufs forcément ça doit
influencer quelques personnes c'est pour
ça qu'ils font des plus justement
mais personnellement et sur instagram on
ne trouvait juillet des chocolats des
deux produits qui vous intéresse je
l'étais checcolo
ses influences ses publicités là mais ça
dépend mais vu qu'on les voit souvent on
rit jeunes adolescents sont visés par
toutes sortes de produits plus est
présentement la loi n'interdit pas la
publicité destinée à ses enfants parce
que caresse minarro si une loi pour
l'ensemble du pays s'impose selon cette
professeur spécialisé en droit de la
santé on parle pas non plus d'interdire
ils ont d'interdire les chips on dit
pourquoi est-ce qu'on prépare une mesure
qui permet de réduire l'incitation
allons manger
ils vont souvent même et plus ans et
leurs amis en partageant ses publicités
ça me dérange pas de savoir que tu es en
train dé d'une compagnie à vendre des
produits mais j'avais jamais vu ça comme
ça ça vous inquiète de voir qu'ils sont
sollicités au teint ah oui absolument
mais qu'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est
peut-être la sensibilisation l'éducation
à les parents nous avons un très grand
rôle à jouer les enseignants et les
parents surtout d'ailleurs il y avait un
projet de loi fédéral pour protéger les
enfants
il a été abandonné entre autres parce
que l'industrie alimentaire s'est
objectée à plusieurs aspects de ce
projet de loi
à ce jour le gouvernement a toujours
dans ses priorités
une loi qui ciblerait la publicité de
malbouffe destinés aux enfants
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
regarde cette situation là en ce moment
il faut vraiment clair que notre société
développe une solution technologique
pour réduire le montant de marketing et
les enfants voient sont internes
moi j'y pense souvent aux lois sur le
tabac jeux même dû son monte un temps on
voulait que ça serait pas possible puis
là aujourd'hui on a de multiples
interdictions et des mesures si vous
croyez que vos enfants sont ciblés
directement par une publicité vous
pouvez contacter la coalition poids qui
vous aidera porter plainte
d'ailleurs nous leur avons soumis ce
produit qui évite directement les
enfants à venir jouer à des jeux et à
découvrir les dernières nouvelles sur
leur site internet
selon la coalition poids il ya matière à
porter plainte